nous sommes le 25 avril 1849 des
émeutiers anglophone incendie le
parlement du canada-uni à montréal la
raison une loi pour dédommager les
victimes quand la rébellion a été
réprimée en 1837 et 38
le lendemain de l'incendié le premier
ministre louis hippolyte lafontaine est
directement visé sa maison est attaquée
des coups de feu sont tirés on a décidé
de garder les marques des impacts de
cette fusillade là donc on peut voir par
exemple ici un impact de la balle
frappée la maison le bâtiment est
désormais figé dans son état de 1849
restaurer le plus fidèlement possible
il s'intègre dans un immense ensemble de
tours à condos centre ville le promoteur
a consacré environ 6 millions de dollars
pour la maison ont lancé à engager de
travail évidemment très exigeant qui a
duré six ans car avant d'arriver à ça le
bâtiment a failli tomber en ruines
abandonnées pendant 30 ans squatter puis
délaissé chaque pierre de la façade a
été retiré numérotée nettoyer un
résultat qui est à la hauteur des
espérances de hockey amateur tout à
l'heure c'est bien vous mettez la barre
haute pour des projets il faut ça il
faut qu'il y ait de l'émulation montréal
n'entend pas se positionner pour acheter
la maison qui n'est pas encore fini à
l'intérieur mais la ville espère que le
futur propriétaire saura faire vivre
l'histoire des débuts de la démocratie
au canada s'est écrite en partie entre
ses murs si mathieu prost radio canada
montréal